this isn't for me a technique
for women because if I do this and now
do this
the technique has to rub up
through my breastbone all right and
that's you know possibly rude for ladies
to do that so I mean I don't know you
know but so if I do this
I've got a chance now when you drop this
elbow and countering me and
punishment or whatever
so it depends how strong you are
you know so if you do it so I'm just
saying for women you know if you take it
off your breastbone
now she started it I can feel it getting
strong against me so I'm gonna get even
stronger
right so so I'm afraid
to me it's not like
performance technique
because it needs to be there so she
doesn't feel my strength she doesn't
feel much strength she feels it near
when I start returning
see but here
see I can turn as much of a light as you
go yeah or I'm going to punch in the
face
all right so
because I'm old I'm not sure about the
gender neutral and all the other
technology words that we have to use now
I'm just saying it's not a great
technique for ladies because you've got
to use strength you know if you're
looking after your own body you've got
to think
so this technique has to go up the bread
bottom so that you don't move straight
like those all about not using strength
so I was reading about those scents here
when you've got a 70 there's a lot of
techniques he didn't do
issue
but if we do this one
now I think our same here
even that doesn't look like a thank you
because I've got this arm up that's it
so that's the main thing so let's just
I'm going to get out all the way
just lock her here but this hair and
watched this home I'm going to take hold
of the rest
and then when it gets to about there see
this hand now is coming to me so that
she doesn't get away from me now
this can be done without using strength
and you you find the mechanics
very simple as you'll see when try and
do it